throw to have him right here in person
to talk about his 50 years in the
Association as well as his new book
called character carved in stone about
the 12 Corps virtuals of virtues of West
Point that build leaders and produce
success he is none other than senior
vice president of the Red Hot eighth
place Orlando Magic Pendleton good to
see you sir [ __ ] I'm so thrilled to be
here nice to see this set up thank you
so much studio I mean you can play every
sport in the world in here you can
pretty much do a little bit of that it's
we you know the one thing we can't do is
shoot hoops we have a very we do have a
very low ceiling play a football game in
here you could probably take batting
practice we could do a little bit we can
roll some putts like golf gala you being
someone who lives in Central Florida
knows all about off capital or the world
it is indeed that it is indeed that so
let's talk quickly about euro your magic
here first the six-game win streak you
guys are flat-out in the mix currently
when I you know obviously back in the
hey there you're an eighth place team
but that is a significant thing to be
obviously in this day and age where did
this six-game win streak come from well
it's a good question we've been battling
away all year or we've had our ups and
downs and suddenly in the last several
weeks the team has caught fire mm-hmm I
don't think there was much of a shot at
the playoffs even six weeks ago but
they're playing with great consistency
and great focus give coach Steve
Clifford a lot of credit we've been
healthy that's a big part of it and and
the key here has been the defensive end
we've held clubs under a hundred points
by and large which is tough to do in
this current age where the ball is
flying up from all angles every night
and the best part of it is the City of
Orlando has gotten excited again about
their magic yeah I know I can feel it a
game behind the nets for sixth place a
huge game tonight the team half game in
front of you you're the Detroit Pistons
and the heats right behind with the with
the Charlotte Hornets right behind all
that I mean what what do you think about
the evolution of the game where
three-pointers are better or viewed as a
better shot than say a mid-range jumper
or something like that
well rich I'm enjoying it I'm
I'm go back in this leap into 1968 so
I've seen every single possible
evolution of the game right these are
the greatest athletes we've ever seen
these young men playing the game today
from all over the world by the way there
are a hundred NBA players from other
countries on rosters right now but I
love the way it is you know there was a
long period when the coaches had the
tight rein you know on on the game and
their teams and their players but it's
it's wide open now Devin Booker goes for
50 again last night and James Harden on
any given night gonna get you 40 to 60
and I'm enjoying it immensely yeah I
mean you you you look at it it is such
more of a wide-open game and you talk
about how best athletes on the planet
now here comes ion and I know that
obviously these are there are rules
about talking or what-have-you but I
think he's coming out for sure and I
know you're a guy that that drafted
Barkley back in the day would you say
that's the best comparison or LeBron is
a better comparison for what we're
seeing of those two who's on could well
he's got some Barclays in him
he's got some Karl Malone in him he's
got some Shawn Kemp in him
maybe he's a combination of all of them
I first learned about him rich my my
roots in
sports go back to Spartanburg South
Carolina hmm I was the general manager
of the Phillies farm club there in the
mid to late 60s that's where it all
started for baseball yes okay and so so
my friends in in Spartanburg have been
telling you about this high school
phenom for a number of years it's been
kind of interesting to track but the
thing I like about him what he competes
and there's a there's a wonderful joy
about him on the court you can tell he
loves to play and he's a great team guy
and his teammates like it hmm
so it's been great fun to watch him but
he's he's a combo platter that we
haven't seen before
yeah I know I guess we're you're hearing
like
bran is more of maybe a comp because of
just his size and the and the maneuvers
that he could make are so difficult to
stop me once he's going you can't you
can't stop him well the big guy and he's
got the footwork of a ballet dancer
mm-hmm
he handles the ball he can bring it up
courting it he and the fact that he's
left-handed doesn't hurt right that
that's an adjustment for people to kind
of get used to the lefties
but Barkley was that way rich he take
the ball off the board and then dribbled
out of traffic
pick up speed at midcourt put it behind
his back
make a dazzling past somebody on the
wing or Charles would keep it himself
and go up and slam it through and I mean
and you came away saying how could a guy
that big and that huge do all that right
well Big Z can do it and it's it's been
fun to watch he's been an attraction all
winter long for all basketball fans what
was Charles like coming out of college
say that again what was Charles like
coming out of college well he was big
we had the fifth pick in that draft in
1984 and that was the Michael Jordan
Olajuwon Draft we had made a trade years
before with the Clippers we had their
pick it turned out to be the fifth pick
right in that draft and this guy who
didn't get a lot of coverage out of
Auburn University basketball people knew
him but not many others did we brought
him in he was six foot four rich that's
it and 292 pounds come on those were the
dimensions and we brought him in we had
a little work out with him we wondered
we sat him down and said Charles we're
seriously interested in you but we're
concerned about this weight we're gonna
bring you back in two months right
before the draft and we'd like to see
you down in the 250s
when we brought him back and he weighed
292
and I said Charles let me let's have a
serious talk here have you been eating
recently before the from the six major
food groups he said yes sir mr. Williams
and they're only two left I mean we knew
this kid was off the chart and I hadn't
explained to him I said Charles a a
balanced meal is not a Big Mac in both
hands anyway he came unsigned and played
in the summer league that summer at
Princeton that was quite a telling sign
you know he hadn't he didn't have a
contract yet and he was terrific
so we spent the entire rest of the
summer you know two pages of wait
clauses mm-hmm in his contract but he
came back to training camp as a rookie
and weighed 252 and we never looked at
those weight clauses again didn't have
to write because Charles was was all
business and he played his whole career
e64 so he's guarding on any given night
Kevin McHale you know down in the in the
post right yeah Kevin Willis I mean he's
guarding these 611 seven-foot power
forwards his whole career and and yes
they gave him some problems but he gave
them a lot more I think a lot of folks
remember will forget
he was nicknamed with those the round
mound of rebound out of Auburn that's
right there's never anybody quite like
Charles no I mean to this day I mean
he's just as a human being
Pat Williams here on the Rich Eisen show
what what was the first time you met
Shaq was the first time you met him well
we won that lottery in 92 and everybody
knew that was not a hard decision Alonzo
Mourning was in that draft Christian
Laettner was in that draft but everybody
knew it was it was a Shaq draft and we
won the lottery and his agent
immediately started to play coy Leonard
armato
yes yes we're very pleased at parole and
oh that is very very good for their
franchise and yeah he very coy and we
couldn't get him in to work him out or
look at him or meet him finally two days
before the draft we word came that Shaq
will come over for a visit
so he flew over with his father sergeant
Harrison mm-hmm and boy he was
everything you would expect a sergeant
to be and his younger brother Jamal and
there they come on a private plane and
we got him in the car I took Jamal over
to our house to play all afternoon with
our 18 children that's not a miss friend
and we just left him there all afternoon
and and Jamal you know they had
sandwiches and all and my wife was there
overseeing it Jamal said where the
pickles be mm-hmm
you know we didn't have pickles for his
service so Jill raced off to the store
you know I said Jill whatever it takes
just get the pickles in the meantime we
had Shaq and his father you know touring
around and meeting and going to the
building and you know we were on our
best behavior and then that night the
DeVos the owners were there and the
coaches we had a big room at the hotel
set up for wonderful dinner Shaq and his
younger brother are done at the end of
the table
Maddie Guk is our coach and I are
sitting right down at the end and these
two brothers are having a food fight you
know the the boss is the owners are this
way and Shaq and his brother and their
[ __ ] bread at each other and stealing
food off their plates and row later I
said Maddie what did you what did you
think of that what was your reaction to
that and he said I didn't know whether
to send him to their room or put him in
quiet time I didn't know what to do with
him right but that was Shaq and Shaq
that's what he was 20 rich big big kid
and he still is he's one of the greatest
nicest
kids still to this day mid-40s November
for late 40s funny we had him on our
show in Atlanta at the Super Bowl
because our set was right down from the
inside the NBA set right there on the
campus of Turner Sports Pat Williams of
the Orlando Magic here and I watched him
walk into our set and we had a studio
audience there and I watched him walk
into her set and he ducked his head
underneath the opening of the door of
our set
but slapped his hand on the back and
made it seem like he had just hit his
head and goes oh and he just made it
seem like he had just hit his head in
front of everybody like he was pulling a
prank on every single one I guess I
guess he's had practice but I think that
it struck me is one of those things that
he's probably been doing his entire life
you know but it's just it's great to
hear these stories so let's talk about
your book here while we have you here on
the show which were thrilled to have you
here Pat it's called character carved in
stone you did not go to West Point
though no okay he did not why did you
decide to write this book rich I got
invited boo Corrigan was the athletic
director there and he invited me to come
up and speak to the teams or sports
teams at the start of the school year
there's several years ago about 600 army
athletes and men and women's teams their
coaches that was a great experience
afterwards they gave me a tour of the
campus and very moving very moving to do
that anyway we end up in a little park
on the edge of the campus called trophy
point looks out over the historic Hudson
River and I noticed in the park a bench
a stone bench which isn't unusual but
twelve benches is unusual twelve benches
and I said I should take a closer look
I'm glad I did normally you would just
see him and leave but I I look closer
and at the end of one bench there was a
word carved into the stone and I kept
checking the benches all the way down
and there was a different word carved
into each bench words like courage
and words like loyalty and integrity
responsibility trust those kind of words
and then my thought was there's got to
be a back story here well there was a
back story the West Point class of 1934
on their 50th reunion gave those benches
as a class gift and these men who had
been through World War two Korea decided
these were the 12 most important words
they had learned in their careers and
wanted to pass that on to future
generations at West Point that was the
back story and then my reaction was boy
this is a well-kept secret you know I
hadn't never heard of that
and then I pitched it to the publisher I
said I think we got a live one here well
we could do a chapter on each word and
then let's try and find out West Point
graduates who best modeled that word and
so that was the background and then
there was one other step who do we want
to do the forward if we get this rolling
well the West Point graduate that I knew
immediately was Mike sous-chefs key who
is a dyed-in-the-wool West Point guy and
he had his career there and we leer when
ton coach there so we asked Mike if he
would do the foreword and he readily
agreed you know and he kept saying I'm
so honored I'm so honored you know but
well we were honored and he did it and
so that's the end result and the book is
out and we're quite encouraged with some
early responses rich and how long how
far back do you go with Coach K when we
tried to hire him when when the Orlando
Magic started up 30 years ago you know I
left Philadelphia in 1986 and moved to
Orlando to try and help make that dream
a reality and bring an expansion team to
Central Florida we were successful and
then right after that you begin thinking
all right now it's real we got to get
ready to play here soon who do we went
to coach when I approached Mike and and
told him we'd love to talk to him at
coming to Orlando and being the coach he
declined declined to even speak to you
about it yes
you didn't even entertain a talk he said
I'm happy here you know I'm uh I'm gonna
stay here so since that rich other pro
teams have approached him boston lakers
different times and he's he's totally
committed to Duke but I this was 30
years ago Mike would have been in his
early 40s then he's early 70s now yeah
but he hadn't quite gotten to being
legendary at that point and but very
highly regarded then but he didn't even
entertain no idea no did you did you
guys speak to Enzo recently too did you
no no no that was Cleveland who's
Cleveland I think I think Tom's in the
right place what makes you think a
college coach could perform well
obviously we've seen Brad Stevens do
very well the Celtics but it usually
hasn't gone very well the other way over
college to the NBA not recently and the
reason for that rich is that we now have
a large pool of assistant coaches to
choose from hmm back way back when I
first started in 1968 there were no team
had an assistant coach now every team
has seven but that's beside the point
but Jack Ramsay had come out of Saint
Joe's and Joe Mullaney had come out of
Providence and dick Motta had come out
of Weber State and John McLeod had come
out of Oklahoma and you know there was a
whole wave and the reason was if you
wanted a coach there was no where else
to look
other than retired players and there
were some of them or college but but now
we've got this huge pool of assistants
and that's where a lot of the hiring
takes place so the the college it's a
big adjustment it's it's a huge jump and
by and large Brad Stevens I think is
kind of an anomaly he seems like it but
he's done very well definitely he's fit
in well but it's it's a whole different
world Rich's a college guy could be
absolutely overwhelmed by this last one
for you in the current day and age do
you need a super team to win a
championship in the NBA no I think it
helps
I think it helps to have three great
outstanding players but do you need it
do you think you can build a team and
win in this era where so many star
players are saying let's all get
together potentially and and form up a
super this is not really new back in
back in our day we went out and bought
julius erving for three million dollars
right and gave him a contract worth
three million well we already had George
McGinnis who was a legendary ABA player
he was there and we had a young Darryl
Dawkins who we had brought out of high
school and he was there and and so uh
and at the time there was a lot of
complaint all--what of the Sixers doing
there they're just muscling up here and
it's not fair and well I thought it was
fair you know our job was to put the
greatest product out there we could we
had we had a vibrant Doug Collins on
that team you know it was a traveling
Roadshow so it's nothing new to go out
and get great players you could argue
with Red Auerbach he had koozie and he
had all these guns and quips that deal
together and now he brings along Bill
Russell it's not fair that all the time
well he went all the time and right he's
in the Hall of Fame that's what it's
about in our business well Pat Riley sit
it well there are two things in the NBA
winning and misery right that Pat and I
and let me tell you something rich I
have learned misery is awful to go home
after you've lost a game it's awful
mm-hmm and and and you know what you
think we're never gonna win another game
we may never win another game that our
schedule we got this team and that team
coming up it's you better win and
because they have a strange custom in
our business after a certain period of
time if you have not produced enough w's
did you see the paper this week all the
college coaches yeah who are gone yes
indeed I know I mean men and women god
it's crazy but at least yells rich well
your team hasn't had mail in a while six
straight wins good luck tonight against
Detroit and
good luck down the road and you're
welcome here anytime sir well I'm so
happy we could get together rich thank
you I'm back at you right back at you
thank you again character carved in
stone by Pat Williams the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience